so let's get started it's a it's a real
pleasure to have um
uh nathan beep here from university of
uh toronto
um
nathan has been
you know
as you as you probably know he's he's
he's done work very broadly and deeply
in these subjects of
quantum machine learning and
and as well as quantum simulation so
he's a he's a great person to tell us
about
this topic of baron plateaus and quarter
machine learning
so
nathan as always
great thank you very much umash it's
it's wonderful to be here um
as always you know i wish i could be
here in person uh because simon's is an
absolutely amazing place to visit but uh
soon i hope
um in any case uh so today i'm going to
be talking about something that you know
has been a real passion of mine for
quite some time which is specifically
trying to understand how we can uh
practically learn in a quantum world
and this is to me the heart of the
question of quantum machine learning
for you know since since the kind of the
development of machine learning as well
as information theory we've begun to get
a much better idea of what it means to
learn pieces of information about
physical systems but many of the
insights that we've developed over the
last couple of years
in the form of deep learning and neural
networks
they don't really actually naturally map
as cleanly as we would like over to the
quantum world and so what my main
motivation for all of this work
ultimately is is i really would like to
understand what it would mean
for a quantum agent to learn based on
quantum data and the type of learning
that we're going to be talking about
here is a type of learning that people
often don't talk about as much in
machine learning specifically generative
learning
and but the reason why we're going to be
doing this is because of the promise
that generative learning uh can offer
under some circumstances to run and just
address issues of a gradient decay that
we end up seeing for this
and so um let me just see
okay yeah so the question is though from
a practical level what what would we
like to do in machine learning deep down
um the way
quantum machine learning usually ends up
working practically or at least for many
of our current conception of how quantum
neural networks work we often view them
as some kind of a parameterized unitary
here i called it unn of theta
and we have it for our system a set of
neurons now these neurons correspond to
a bunch of quantum bits and what we
would really like to be able to do is
we'd like to be able to take some
initial state and transform it with a
parameterized unitary in order to get a
final state and choose those parameters
in such a way so that when we measure
a particular observable on that we can
extract some salient features from the
state
and many of you might think hey wait a
sec doesn't this sound like exactly the
same as vqe and qaoa
and you know the truth of the matter is
at this level for uh in terms of
optimizing an objective function
it's very very similar and many of these
problems that i'm going to be talking
about involving gradient decay for these
show up in exactly the same way across
many different areas however i'm going
to be focusing on on qml applications in
this talk
um one of the things that i should
mention is that you know there's a
number of uh different ways though that
we can solve this apart from
necessarily just resorting to
variational optimization for an
objective that we're looking at we can
use the standard quantum algorithms that
have been developed for years such as
grover search linear systems algorithms
gradient descent algorithms and the like
in order to be able to provide
accelerations for uh these quantum
algorithms it should be mentioned that
although many of these algor some of the
several of these algorithms in principle
offer exponential speed ups for these
particular tasks it's very you've got to
be very very careful looking for
exponential speed ups for quantum
machine learning tasks and i i would say
for cases where there's classical data
coming in and we would like to use
quantum machine learning to do this
better
almost all actually all of the
techniques that i'm aware of right now
only lead to polynomial speedups for
those cases rather than exponential and
so what the big question for me given
the fact that we really would like to
see a huge speed up for any early
application for quantum is kind of well
what sort of speed ups do we end up
getting for these variational ideas
which often come with fewer uh
complexity bounds
than the rest of the algorithms that i
discussed
and further you know
the i guess the question is
what can we do for problems that are
more situated in the quantum world where
we're trying to learn information
directly about or from quantum states
and so
the
question one of the key questions that
we're going to be asking here is could
we use these particular ideas in order
to be able to come up with ways of
preparing quantum states that might be
far more efficient than
the naive methods that we would try to
design by hand in order to prepare
particular quantum states
so these are kind of some of the big
hopes about it and you know just to give
you an idea about how this this works
schematically all of these
algorithms end up
working the same what we do is we need
to begin with some data that we would
like to learn something about or we'd
like to classify
and so in order for us to kind of use a
quantum computer in order to be able to
do this we need to map that data from
whatever representation we start with to
a state in the quantum computer so you
know this is well is often done by some
encoding transformation which you can
view in the classical site is even run
by its own classical neural network that
might compress the data into a small
representation that we could then store
in the quantum computer
alternatively if we have quantum data in
many cases that data itself might be a
quantum state in those cases a
encoding transformation may not actually
even be needed to load the algorithm the
data into your algorithm however you
could consider trying to compress it
using an idea like a quantum auto
encoder or something similar to that
so once you've loaded your data in in
one way or another you need to be able
to uh train a classifier or get it in
some particular way so we can map to a
final state that when we measure an
objective function will tell us how well
we're actually learning
about the the data and then our goal at
least in the these types of machine
learning algorithms work very much like
neural networks is to optimize the
parameters of this transformation in
such a ways to maximize our objective
function
all right and that that's basically the
end of the game now the question about
how to optimize those parameters is kind
of you know uh well it's a good one and
it's a general one the way that we often
and uh like thinking about this is in
terms of gradient descent
and so this uh however many of the
features that make can make gradient
descent expensive will make most other
uh local optimizers that you take a look
at expensive so i'm going to be focusing
on this talk entirely upon gradient
descent optimization for this of course
but of course recognizing the fact that
there's other optimization strategies
that could be used
so to give you and the next question is
what would one of these quantum neural
networks actually look like that is one
of these parameterized unnns of theta
so here's an example of of one from a
paper that i did with maria shoulder now
a fairly long time ago
but the basic idea behind behind it is
that what we do similar to an ordinary
neural network is we take all of our
data we encode it in quantum states and
then we have a series of controlled uh
operations so these g's in this case
represent arbitrary single qubit
rotations
so if you use an euler angle
decomposition every one of the g's that
you end up seeing in this uh this
decomposition
would be given by three parameters
and so you can you can see that there's
a fairly large number of parameters that
we end up having in this particular
quantum circuit now just give you an
example of a of a classification task
that we could try to solve for this is
we could say all right well let's try to
determine whether or not our
state is from class row class one or
class zero so for example you know we
would have row one might be a mixed
state that's of the form sum over all
these phi j's over here and rho 0 which
is a state that could be in class 0
would be a sum over all of these psi j's
and the basic idea is that we would have
these two kind of distributions which
might be a uniform distribution over
training examples and what we would like
to be able to do is given an example
that we don't know necessarily as a phi
or a psi we would like to be able to
come up with a circuit that's capable
with high probability of classifying
between them
although recognizing that in this
context the the two vectors may not be
orthogonal so we may not actually be
able to have unambiguous discrimination
between the uh states in both of these
classes so what we would do in this
particular case is we would you know
choose we would encode our data in such
a way so that we have the label
uh stored along with each of the vectors
that we're considering for this
particular case
and then what we would like to do is
when we measure this top qubit over here
we'd like the measurement to match the
label that we have associated with it
and so basically the
natural objective function for us to
optimize would be the average rate at
which we end up getting the correct
label coming back out of it all right so
then we would just use gradient descent
on all of these like three n angles that
we end up getting for all the g's that
are in here and try to try to optimize
it
so that's the basic idea of what this
ends up looking like now
this leads to the big nightmare of
quantum machine learning which actually
ironically comes from the greatest hope
that we have from quantum machine
learning and that is that quantum
quantum states exist in very high
dimensional spaces and from that
perspective you can view a quantum
computer as basically just a giant
vector
but the problem is is that that strength
comes with the fact that this is a
gigantic hilbert space that we're
operating in
and so something that ends up happening
kind of generically is that you tend to
actually get lost in high dimensional
spaces or another way of putting it is
high dimensional spaces tend to actually
have some typicality properties
so for most functions on high
dimensional spaces or most well-behaved
functions in high dimensional spaces you
tend to actually have what's known as a
concentration of measure
meaning that most of the values that you
evaluate these these functions at tend
to actually be concentrated about the
same value
and so when we carry this out the
problem is is that if we end up having
this situation where there's a
concentration of measure nearly all
initial parameters that we'll end up uh
choosing
for our guesses for these
angles for the g's that we end up having
in this circuit will yield to basically
the same performance
and so this can lead to a problem
because of the fact that if just about
every configuration gives you the same
value then the gradients will tend to be
very small and in fact exponentially
small
so nathan there's a there's a question
in the q a um which says well beyond
beyond this sort of
small gradients
why is it believed that the parameter
optimization is a convex problem you
know why could you not get stuck oh
it's to be right
it's not believed to be a convex problem
whatsoever
so this is actually something that
happens in machine learning as well like
uh for for training neural networks in
practice what ends up happening is when
you train it you do not ever find the
local optima for training an ordinary
neural network instead you find yourself
close to a local optima in practice
every single time and the idea well the
thing that empirically tends to end up
happening is that often the local optima
that we end up finding tend to tend to
be good enough for people's purposes
so this raises and another question
which is which is a fantastic one and a
hard one which is you know in practice
if we're looking at the optimization
landscape are the local optima good for
quantum classifiers or are they actually
really strongly suboptimal
and the truth is is that we don't know
and also we don't know if it's strongly
believed from complexity theoretic
arguments that it's not possible for us
in general to be able to solve the
global optimization problem
otherwise you know we would have bqps
and qma in these
sorry it is in q a but uh qmas and bqp
in these cases so that that's some of
the reasons moral stories yeah we don't
expect it's convex and that's that's an
open question about how much it impacts
us
cool all right
so this
effect that though that the gradients
end up shrinking to some negligible
scale typically
for these problems leads to what's known
as a barren plateau
okay so let me give you an idea about
what a barren plateau is really kind of
all about the way i like thinking about
it is you know imagine that you're
you've got a runner
okay
and
the runner decides rather foolishly to
go out running and
uh near a cliff
the problem is this runner in particular
also happens to be blind
okay so the idea basically is that you
know the runner in principle when it's
nice and flat right the runner you'd
want it wants to run really really fast
and that's optimal until the runner ends
up getting to the edge of the cliff
sadly if the runner is blind then
what'll happen if they're going quickly
is they'll go crashing back down
any analog of this you know running
towards a cliff problem is the exact
same thing that ends up happening with
the baron plateaus problem
it turns out that from the generic
convergence proofs that we end up
needing for gradient descent
um we need to end up taking steps that
are uh proportional
to
the um inverse of the lipschitz constant
for the function that we're taking a
look at
uh or sorry the lipschitz constant of
the gradient that we're taking a look at
so
the gradient is nearly constant at first
right everything's nice and flat so if
that this was our entire problem just
like the runner we could take huge steps
and it wouldn't really impact anything
the problem is is that as we get towards
the cliff
the derivative is changing
discontinuously in the vicinity of the
cliff
and so the lip shit's constant that we
need in order to make sure that the
runner survives the potential uh fall
down the cliff
ends up leading to really tiny steps
that we have to make everywhere and we
have to make that everywhere because the
runner has no idea in practice when
they're going to actually take a step at
that and step over the edge of the cliff
and so this is the problem is that if
we've got a large lip lipshit's constant
for our derivative
but we end up in a region that locally
has a tiny derivative then gradient
descent requires us to take a ton of
tiny little steps and
it ends up taking an exponential time
for us to navigate this barren plateau
there's methods that you know can be
used in order to partially mitigate
these problems but for various reasons
that many of them are either impractical
to do on a quantum computer such as you
know evaluating the second derivative uh
that you end up having for the the
runner going through
and uh others are also just
um
um
well they end up requiring too strong
information about the landscape such as
knowing where the cliff is
or are an exact solution like giving the
runner some momentum from the previous
steps to help them carry through their
gradients through regions of a flat
slope
so all of these problems are um are huge
challenges for any gradient descent
algorithm and they are especially bad
for quantum gradient descent
but to give you an idea about why the um
of the these problems end up showing up
let me give you a toy example um which
will give you the hint of why these uh
of the objective functions tend to be
flat for high dimensional spaces
often the kind of objective functions
that we're looking at in quantum
computing quantum computing in these
cases are problems or where we want to
be able to figure out what the overlap
is between a current state that's
generated by a quantum neural network
and some kind of a target state
so you know that ends up looking like
the uh overlap of some phi and some psi
squared
now let's assume that psi
is a random uh state of the form given
above with angles going from theta one
to theta two to the n okay so we have
all of these different components and
these values theta are chosen at random
if we average over all of those angles
we end up finding that the expected
overlap between these two states is 1
over 2 to the n however if we go through
the exact same calculation for the
variance of that expectation value we
end up finding that the variance is 1
over 2 to the 3n
which means that the standard deviation
is in order
1 over 2 to the 3n over 2
which is vastly smaller than the mean
and this is something again that we
could refer to as a concentration of
measure it means that virtually all of
the examples that we take a look at
virtually all of the size
are going to have exponentially small
overlap with the five that we took a
look at if we only had the mean then we
could have some really fat tails where
there might be some a large fraction of
the vectors that do have high reasonable
overlap
but by bounding the variance like this
it guarantees that actually
almost all uh randomly chosen vectors
are nearly orthogonal
and this ends up leading to these
situations where
it causes yeah the
expectation to be concentrated now the
problem of doing this outside or i
should say this particular problem where
we're looking at states that are of the
form that i showed on a previous slide
is actually just kind of looking at one
slice
of the total uh unit sphere that quantum
states can sit in or hypersphere i
should say that quantum states would sit
in in a high dimensional space in
general we need to actually do a similar
argument but over the entire space
and the way that we do this rather than
doing this simple integral over all of
these angles theta one through theta two
to the n is we need to do what's called
a har average
where the har measure is um is basically
the unitarily invariant measure uh over
unitaries in a um in an n-dimensional
space and that average that you end up
taking a look at for it uh it's also a
lot more difficult practically to be
able to do the uh the integrals because
there isn't as nice parameterizations
for it so in practice these are
integrals can be done but symmetry
arguments are usually used rather than
an explicit integral like i showed you
and so for that reason i wanted to show
you the explicit integral to give you a
spirit of the spirit of how these argue
these concentration arguments end up
working but the specific techniques for
doing the har average are a little bit
different than than the ones that i
mentioned before
so
that is uh basically how this ends up
working and um
yeah we end up finding again a
concentration of measure for this uh
when we do a horror average as well
but getting back to machine learning uh
one of the things that we want to do is
we really again want to maximize the
objective function for this
uh we can end up talking about well
what's the
typical value of the objective function
under the assumption that our neural
network ends up giving a unitary that's
typical of those that we would draw
randomly from the har measure
now this
question of typicality is kind of a is a
good one like is this an appropriate
assumption to model our neural networks
by a hard random unitary and
it's somewhat debatable actually
but in cases where you end up having a
large number of purely random gates
stacked together
random gates has been drawn from a
universal set tend to form at least
what's known as an approximate uh two
design
and what that ends up meaning is like at
least the second moments of the
distribution that you end up getting
from random gates end up matching the
distribution that you would end up
expecting from a har random unitary
so that means that many of the
characters that you would end up seeing
from some totally arbitrary gate
sequence
end up actually matching those from the
har random model so it's often
reasonable in these circumstances to try
to understand how a totally random quan
a randomly initialized quantum neural
network would perform compared to
the the heart measure
so we if we end up taking that uh that
model for what a unit a unitary neural
network ends up looking like we end up
finding that you know our objective
function
uh ends up sca again
uh scaling like the um
like one over two to the n typically for
these uh particular cases
i shouldn't have put an arg max there
but you you get the idea
so
basically going through the exact same
type of arguments about the variance as
well we end up finding with probability
one over virtually all the random
initializations that we would get under
this har random model
ends up leading us to quantum neural
networks that predicts virtually nothing
so it says almost all random uh
initializations for the for quantum
neural networks are next to useless
so okay
great but
the question is
can gradients end up saving us
because all we ended up showing before
yeah or that argument ends up leading to
before is that
the
concentration of good parameters for
neural networks is incredibly low but
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
bad parameters for neural networks
aren't immediately adjacent to good
neural networks and in those cases
gradient descent might actually save the
day
but it turns out unfortunately
generically we don't expect this to be
true
but in order to show this we need to
kind of make a little bit more of a um
more special assumptions about the
functional form of our quantum neural
network to affer to to do this so the
standard a standard assumption that's
used is that we end up assuming that our
quantum neural network ends up taking
the form of a product of a bunch of um
exponentials of hamiltonians
with a with a number of theta j's being
our individual parameters for these
so
as you can see the the you know the
previous case where we're dealing with
you know single qubit rotations and
controlled single cubic rotations
we can view each of those as a having a
decomposition in terms of exponentials
of hamiltonians like this uh form over
here so this is relatively generic
so if we end up assuming we have an
onsites like this
then we can actually go through and
compute the derivative of this onsodz
with respect to one of the parameters
and just by using the product rule over
this we end up getting the um the
following expression here for the
derivative
which basically ends up looking like the
hamiltonian corresponding to that
parameter we're differentiating
with respect to conjugated by a bunch of
those unitaries over here
now at this point we've got now like um
two unitaries that end up coming in we
end up um
basically uh getting a like a a v
unitary as well as a w unitary and we've
got the um u of theta unitary
let's now go through and model all of
those as being uh har random unitaries
if we go and do that then we end up
finding the derivative of this is equal
to this expectation value all right this
result over here
and going through the har averaging of
this leads to a uh the result that for
all but an exponentially small fraction
of the parameters that we end up picking
in this case we end up seeing that the
um
um
that the expectation value of our
observable is uh exponentially small or
every gradient is exponentially small
so this ends up meaning that basically
gradients typically if this har random
model ends up being appropriate which it
often is
then actually gradient descent will not
be enough in order to get us away
from this barren plateau situation i was
talking about previously
where
we have extremely small gradients going
going up before we end up hitting a
regime where we can finally start making
progress in our objective function
so this is a major major problem
conceptually right how do we
how do we deal with these problems of
having tiny gradients
in this
now
the answer is well classically one of
the things that we can get by with is we
can get by with the fact that we have
access to high precision arithmetic if
we need to have 16 digits of accuracy
when it comes to our gradient
calculations
for most classical algorithms at least
most deterministic classical algorithms
that that isn't a problem we can compute
to double precision you know just using
ordinary arithmetic
however for quantum neural networks if
we wanted to be able to compute the
gradient of a function
um
of the type that we were talking about
before which would be something like an
expectation value of an observable
we end up finding that the um under the
assumption that our function is this
from the special class known as a
jeffrey class
then the
number of operations that were accesses
to this function that we would need in
order to be able to evaluate the
gradient
is lower bounded by something that
scales like 1 over epsilon
okay so what if that means our gradient
is like 10 to the minus 16 the value of
epsilon that we would end up needing in
order to just even get the sign
of the gradient correctly is about 10 to
the minus 16 which means that this the
number of steps that we end up needing
would be like 10 to the 16 in order to
be able to uh evaluate even just the
direction that we're taking for the
gradient
and so this ends up meaning that for the
tiny gradients that can sometimes show
up for deterministic classical neural
networks
the number of steps that we would need
in a quantum neural network is truly
frightening in order for us to be able
to evaluate these gradients and so this
is a way in which the tiny gradients
that you're you're seeing end up turning
into a vast number of operations that we
end up needing for a quantum computer to
be able to kind of bushwhack its way out
of the barren plateaus that we expected
to generically find us in
so
that is that this is this is why this is
a horrible problem
so
again
the problem isn't just is from two
aspects right if we want to be able to
try to tackle this the perhaps the the
first way that we could deal with this
is try to inject prior information
because we i said previously that the
typical configuration
of those angles uh ends up giving you a
really bad performance if you have some
insight about what good angles are
before you end up starting
this can actually potentially sidestep
the problem entirely because your
unitary may not be one that's typical of
a her random unitary
and thus all of the arguments which are
which hold for typical har random
unitaries
won't hold for your case
this is a big saving grace for
applications to these ideas in chemistry
for example where we'll often begin with
something like a mean field
approximation to the ground state that
can be found classically easily
and that means that the the these
arguments are less scary yeah in that
setting however for quantum machine
learning it's often a lot more difficult
to be able to impose some prior
knowledge about what the structure of
the classes are that you're trying to
learn for the underlying data
and so this task of navigating the space
is a lot more difficult
so
one avenue and the avenue that i'm going
to be talking about through the rest of
this approach is to actually kind of
flip the script in order to say instead
of looking at you know classification as
a standard problem in quantum machine
learning we i want to ask well do these
um vanishing gradient problems show up
in precisely the same way for generative
tasks
so in particular you know can we end up
uh and this raises the question can we
learn to generate something like this
mean field state
can we you know
carry out some type of a protocol and
find some approximate state that mimics
closely enough
some training distribution that we end
up having and use that as an initial
atypical
starting point for the algorithms from
which we can learn and potentially
sidestep the these concerns that the har
averages that i discussed previously end
up raising
and so
and this again raises the kind of the
bigger question is
you know are generative objective
functions also just as prone to barren
plateaus as the discriminative ones like
the average success probability of a
classifier
okay so just to give you an idea about
what quantum generative uh training
would end up looking like as a following
what we really would like to do is we'd
really like to be able to say feeding
copies of some particular quantum state
the simplest one is just one quantum
state being fed in right and what we
would like to really be able to do is we
really would like to be able to output
some quantum state such that some kind
of a distance and that choice of
distance is entirely up to you
that type of distance between the state
that's output by the generative model
is uh small with respect to the states
that it's trained with
okay
so
that's the basic idea behind it and if
um
we
basically um end up feeding this in
um
let's see oh um
if we basically end up having a state a
situation where we're not just feeding
in a single state but instead we're
feeding in a conditional state we can
also think about that in the exact same
language but what we really need to do
is we need to consider an expectation
value over all of the distinct states
that are fed into it
uh so that's that's basically how you
can end up generating not just a state
but also generating a family of
particular states using this type of an
idea
but a lot of the art behind all of this
ends up uh boiling down to your choice
of distance uh metric for this there's a
number that you could end up picking but
the one i really like is i like relative
entropy for reasons that i'll get into
for a while uh yeah shortly
but another thing that i thought might
end up helping the discussion is to make
it a little more concrete
rather than us talking about generating
like an arbitrary quantum state i'd like
to focus on a particularly important
family of quantum states in particular
i'd like us to talk about generating
what's what are known as gibbs states
the idea behind a gibbs state is a gibbs
state ends up describing the
distribution that a quantum system would
be in
uh if it's allowed to equilibrate at
finite temperature
and so basically the this distribution
is given by this matrix sigma i i i
stated on the left which is e to the
minus h over some quantity known as a
partition function which is its trace so
think about that z it's just some
constant that you need in order to
normalize e to the minus h to be a
proper density matrix
so that's
that's the basic idea behind it and what
we would like to be able to do is we
would like to be able to build a quantum
neural network that contains both
visible as well as some qubits that are
hidden as in they're just latent qubits
that are used to generate correlations
but not directly observed by the end
user
and we'd like to be able to trace over
those hidden variables of the output
state and have that resultant state
after the trace be as close as possible
with respect to your favorite distance
to the gibbs state that we'd want to
generate
and so from that perspective once we
found that then our parameterized
unitary or quantum neural network can be
thought of as building a purification to
the grip's gibbs state or at least an
approximate purification of the gibson
so that's the idea
and so
there's good reason why i i ended up
picking it i give state in particular
which we'll see in a moment but let's
talk about some of the
uh
my favorite distance measure for this my
favorite distance measure to take a look
at the distance between two quantum
states is the quantum relative entropy
for those of you who've spent some time
with
machine learning a quantum relative
entropy is is a analog to the kl
divergence between two uh probability
distributions which is known and loved
in in machine learning circles
it's um
basically defined here as the uh von
neumann entropy of the state on the left
minus the cross entropy between the two
which is the trace rho log sigma and
this particular result is uh really
important for a hypothesis testing you
can end up uh bounding the error that
you end up making in hypothesis testing
between distinguishing between two two
quantum states rho and sigma in terms of
the number of copies that you end up
feeding into the optimal discriminating
circuit
and the relative entropy between the two
states that you're trying to um identify
so it's really that's one of the things
that i really like about it it has a
well motivated information theoretic
basis
uh for it it's got one other property
that's kind of like a mixed bag and that
is just like the kl divergence it's
asymmetric
the
diver the quantum relative entropy
between rho and sigma is not the same as
the quantum relative entropy between
sigma and rho
um
they've got slightly different
interpretations and that's why it's not
symmetric
but
the the key thing is is that the the
double-edged sword about this is that
you can also pick the order of the
divergence that you're taking a look at
to end up matching your computational
needs sometimes one order we'll see is
vastly easier than the other order from
the perspective of computing gradients
so you know my collaborators and i use
that trick all uh frequently in order to
be able to make
models that are easier to train with
respect to one direction of the relative
entropy than the other
um the
but
one thing that ends up coming up is that
um
the
it's often
kind of uh difficult
uh for us to be able to uh optimize this
function one of the main reasons why is
that it involves matrix logarithms and
so we've got to differentiate matrix
logarithms now that's a little bit
difficult because of the fact that when
you differentiate an operator right
you're normally
end up
you often like to use uh the chain rule
so say you have something like this
right you might say oh this is just
equal to
uh what
g prime
of
f prime of g of x something like that
so you can't use the chain rule
uh you could we're sorry one of the
things that fundamentally is used in the
derivation of the chain rule
is you use uh in its derivation the fact
that functions commute with each other
so the
however we're differentiating a matrix
function
and so the derivative of the matrix
logarithm that we end up seeing over
here
isn't something that that actually works
for the chain rule so we have to use
very very cumbersome expressions in
those cases to be able to differentiate
it and so that's why even though it's
information it's
my favorite metric to try to optimize
we don't often do it in practice and in
practice what we'll often do is the
selection is the much easier um rainy
two divergence
the rainy two divergence is this trace
rho squared sigma inverse function
it's known to be an upper bound on the
quantum relative entropy and also ends
up satisfying that the rainy divergence
when you're looking at the rainy
divergence between two states is equal
to the quantum relative entropy is equal
to zero if those two states are the same
so this ends up leading to a situation
where we're trying to optimize a
function like this we really would like
to make d go to zero okay which would be
like the relative entropy in our case
but if we can get
the rainy divergence to go to zero
because it's an upper bound and it's a
tight upper bound near zero pushing the
blue curve to zero also guarantees that
the red curve goes to zero
so this is one of the reasons why
although it's not as good as optimizing
the quantum relative entropy directly
it's the next best thing and it's vastly
easier to optimize because of the lack
of matrix logarithms
and you can see that because it's the
logarithm of the trace here not the
trace logarithm so this is just an
ordinary logarithm that we can
differentiate using ordinary rules of
calculus
okay so
going
yeah sorry there's a question in the
chat so rishi says that they got a bit
lost in between
the question is am i correct in
understanding
so nathan do you see the question in the
q a
oh uh no i i i don't okay
oh the question is uh yeah so so do the
popular variational algorithms like you
and cleo also suffer from baron plateaus
uh and then the other question was about
for qaoa
um
there's some results about how for
random instances
maybe you can extrapolate from a small
instance to a bigger instance and you
know what do you think about the the
general utility of this strategy
yeah i think these are all things that
potentially sidestep these arguments
over uh over here the the problem of
vanishing gradients regardless of your
your approach that's always something
you have to worry about you could show
up even for you know the best use of
prior knowledge and the best choice of
objective function that you're you're
taking a look at however
whether it's typical or not for these
cases where you're extrapolating up in
qaoa or cases like quantum chemistry
where you're approaching the problem
with a lot of prior knowledge it's
really
we really don't have reason to believe
that these barren plateaus are
necessarily typical
but you still could find yourself in one
uh so it's you know it's a perhaps good
to walk out with your machete but you
may not necessarily need to worry about
drop bears
um
so
in any case i just wanted to go through
and
show as show why actually um
looking at gibbs states is so awesome
for the rainy two divergence so
the reason why it's so awesome is take a
look at this right the distance between
the the two states is the trace of rho
squared sigma inverse now
sigma inverse
it's pain to compute normally normally
if you take a look at our full paper on
this we show you know a polynomial
method that you can use that was used in
some lcu uh based approaches to linear
systems algorithms
um but you can we can use that in order
to approximate sigma inverse to do this
for generic state it's cumbersome and
it's expensive
but actually for gibbs states sigma
inverse is trivial to express
because sigma is e to the minus h over z
so sigma inverse is just z times e to
the h
furthermore for the case of the gibbs
state you're told what the hamiltonian
is to begin with
so what you can do
is you can actually just
take the expression for the derivative
and i've skipped a bunch of steps over
here trust me this is the derivative of
the rainy divergence
and then these exponentials of the
hamiltonian we can then tailor expand
those out to an arbitrary order we then
truncate the taylor series in the
numerator and denominator and the entire
problem boils down to computing these
expectation values of different powers
of the hamiltonian multiplied by at
least two density matrices
and so then what we need to do in order
to be able to estimate this is that we
need to be able to basically estimate
both the numerator and denominator with
insufficient error in order to make sure
that the air propagates to epsilon over
the entire result
and we do that essentially just by
either using sampling or because because
i'm nerdy like this uh amplitude
estimation
yeah
so this is where i get nervous when i
see the trade when i see the row squared
and and then combine that with sampling
so
should we be scared here or what you
know sometimes sometimes it's good or
bad
okay you'll talk get more parameters
yeah yeah yeah so sometimes you should
definitely be scared this is not always
going to end up working
um and you know you can you know that
this isn't always going to work because
you know if we were able to always be
able to say variationally train a
unitary that could prepare a low
temperature gibbs state then we'd be
able to actually uh show that qma
lies in bqp so there's got to be some
barriers where the efficiency is just
going to break down completely however
it doesn't break down in all scenarios
so
going through and ask a quick related
question yeah brian um hi nice talk so
far um so if you had told me oh go
prepare gibbs date and i was just
thinking with my physics head on i would
have said oh
eth let me just go ahead and do time
dynamics for a little while and and
uh under tiny accident hamiltonian i'd
expect to get a gift state as long as i
can start with something
reasonable um and i look at your
formulas and they don't quite look like
timer dynamics but i mean they have they
have a flavor of sort of sneakily doing
time dynamics is there any relation here
or is this just totally different things
well the type of approach that i'm using
here is kind of a little bit different
than uh you know using some eth like
argument because you know i i i feel
embarrassed talking about this because
i've only dabbled in quantum
thermodynamics compared to experts like
aram and others um but you know one
thing that at least as far as when i
looked at the literature um
that really you needed to worry about is
you really need to worry about all these
issues of windowing and it was necessary
sometimes to make strong assumptions
about the form of the hamiltonian to
guarantee convergence to the gibbs state
so the nice thing about the about this
type of an approach is that we can
guarantee that we're going to be uh with
an epsilon error of the gibbs state um
with certain computational resources
i would say
that makes sense to me is there any
relation or is this just a totally
different difference i think you kind of
they're kind of different i'm not seeing
any clear relation at the moment
um perhaps actually you know something
that could be done
is if you wanted to think about maybe a
physics-inspired form of a neural
network
for carrying this out it might be
possible uh to
get some advantages over a completely
random hamiltonian sequence if you take
advantage of insights from quantum
thermodynamics but i i haven't put too
much thought into it
great thanks i would say actually
probably the method that's closest to to
doing this
would be um kind of preparing uh gibbs
states using quantum analogs and
metropolis hastings algorithms those
feel to me like they've got the closest
analog to
a physical process because it's very
much like a physical annealing process
that you would carry out
thank you
no problem but in any case for going
through and computing those expectation
values you need to do um you need to
compute expectation values of multiple
units uh multiple hamiltonian terms
which we've assumed are unitary in the
previous uh discussion and we also need
multiple density operators so how do you
do that it's kind of feels like you need
something kind of like
the swap test
but you also need something kind of like
the hadamard test to be able to pull it
off so we
ended up inventing this thing that i
originally called the swap amar test but
sadly my co-authors didn't like that
name so much and i i understand it's
horribly annoying so uh we decided to
call it generalized swap test instead
which does exactly that it'll compute an
arbitrary polynomial
of um
of expectation values and density
operators that we feel like and all of
the terms that we ended up getting in a
previous expression are exactly of that
form
so we can just run this circuit in order
for us to be able to estimate the quad
each of the quantities at hand with an
epsilon error
of course but going back to arum's
question the question is all right well
how small does that epsilon really need
to be in order to make sure that a small
error in the numerator doesn't propagate
into something giant when divided by a
tiny denominator
and uh so
that is um that is
a good question
and uh i won't bore you bore you all
with all the details about the
complexity of this but here's the final
final result for the complexity of using
gradient descent assuming that we've got
a gradient with a function that has a
gradient that slips it's continuous with
lipschitz constant lambda
then the final expression that we end up
getting uh before the complexity ends up
scaling like this where epsilon is our
desired error in the end
so everything that we end up getting in
this ends up depending kind of on the
ratio of this e to the uh
one norm of the coefficients of the
hamiltonian
divided by this other junk over here
so in the event that the trace of the
exponential of the hamiltonian relative
to the this junk at the top
is actually order one
then we're actually we end up getting
into a situation where we can
efficiently using this method estimate
um uh
go through the entire gradient
optimization process
and so this ends up meaning that yeah if
we're looking at a high temperature
gibbs state we can do this
um
but we can't do this uh
in general
so that is uh that's basically kind of
the the situation where we can we can
carry this out
and it works extremely well in practice
though when we actually end up uh taking
a look at this we ended up seeing that
we can train a quantum neural network to
end up building a arbitrary um
thermal state
and uh the other thing that's actually
really kind of neat about this is that
the quality of the prediction actually
ended up getting better systematically
as we improved
provided more and more hidden units to
our quantum neural network previously
work that my collaborators and i had
done showed that often hidden units are
kind of a nightmare scenario for
neural networks that the extra
entanglement will end up actually
causing you to effectively decohere and
the predictive power of your neural
network dying and this is the first time
that i've seen actually big improvements
and coming out of a training scheme
where that actually uses neural networks
because of the use of this different
objective function
so this works really well for learning
states
furthermore when we can actually go
through
this and take a look at whether or not
baron plateaus end up existing for the
this training objective function in
general so this part over here i'm not
specifically just talking about gibbs
states i'm talking about the the general
objective function which is the rainy
divergence between the two when we take
a look at the gradient of it and
actually end up computing the
expectation value
over the the har measure we end up
finding that a lower bound on the
expected uh square of the the derivative
of the rainy divergence is given by this
mess over here so just like aaron was
saying there are some circumstances
where this is miserable
right like
for example if if we end up taking a
look at the case where norm sigma is 1
then this whole thing ends up going like
1 over 2 to the 2n
roughly speaking actually i guess the
trace might be a little bit better than
that but roughly speaking it could be as
bad as 1 over 2 to the 2n uh vincent
you've got a question
yes hi uh i was wondering about the
previous slide where you showed that
the
training is better with a higher number
of hidden units
yeah and i i was curious what the
dimension of the
gibbs state you were trying to
prepare was oh gosh i didn't i didn't
put it here i believe that it was a four
cubit uh gibbs state uh plus you know a
number of uh extra hidden qubits equal
to the number of hidden units over here
so it's anywhere between four and seven
uh qubits that we were looking at right
okay so it didn't have to be
greater than uh
the dimension of the target state that's
interesting yeah
yeah cool thanks uh
you got a question yes um yeah sorry um
so so i'm
wondering if you're not comparing really
orange to apples by comparing the baron
plateau in the um discriminative
algorithm compared to to this because
now what you
are comparing at the output is this um
kl divergence of of your
output state which in itself will
require an exponentially large number of
measurements in order to measure that
number
beautiful question
yes this is one of the things that i
really like about this objective
function
the relative entropy is very difficult
to be able to estimate directly um but
actually its gradients are
aren't bad at all
so this is something that actually ended
up also showing up in ordinary machine
learning with the kl divergence
k the kl divergence is hard to estimate
but the gradients of the kl divergence
often can be estimated by statistical
sampling
so we end up in a similar situation here
under under circumstances where the
complexity of the gradient evaluation is
is reasonable which happens in some
cases
then
we can actually optimize the relative
entropy
but finding the value of the relative
entropy at the end of it may still be
exponentially hard
i see
i'm okay maybe
maybe i can ask at the end but i'm
wondering how
computing the gradients is easy um
maybe
okay i can i can try that that really
quick it's not necessarily easy
but it's basically the reason why is
that the gradients
end up taking the form of some type of a
function that ends up looking like this
uh for the generic k if the generic case
that isn't a gibbs state we end up
having polynomial expansions from the uh
from a polynomial expansion of the
inverse of the the second operation but
it spiritually ends up looking the same
that what we've got to do is we've got
to take a expectation value of a bunch
of density operators sandwiched between
a bunch of different hamiltonian terms
and that's something that we can
evaluate using this circuit and so then
it just really boils down to what these
ratios are and the ratios aren't
necessarily horrible they can be in some
cases but they're not necessarily
horrible kind of like you know learning
the partition function more or less is
almost necessarily horrible
okay
so
okay key point i know i'm running low on
time
is that the
in this particular case if we're dealing
with a situation where the norm of sigma
is like one that's kind of like this
nightmare situation that arum was uh was
referring to and baron the lower bounds
that we can prove don't necessarily end
up precluding that we have uh a barren
plateau
however in the case where the norm of
sigma is exponentially small which is a
case where you know our states are very
high temperature and very distributed
then actually these these lower bounds
end up giving a value that's kind of on
the order of one
and this ends up kind of uh showing a
that the barren plateaus that we end up
seeing generically for most of the
discriminative uh training objectives
that have been considered so far don't
necessarily need to apply for the jet
for generative objective functions like
the quantum relative entropy or the
rainy divergence
and in part a lot of this ends up coming
coming into uh into here from the fact
that when you take a derivative of a
logarithm you automatically kind of
normalize the derivative if something's
small on the numerator it ends up being
paired with something small in the
denominator and that under certain
circumstances can actually uh
save the day when it comes to the
expectation
so
the question is all right this is and
this part of the talk is a little more
speculative
it's it goes to this question of
can we uh end up finding a generative a
pre-training algorithm
can we use this this generative training
over here as an initial step towards a
building a better classifier by using
this in order to get us outside of the
baron baron plateau
and this idea can work uh quite well in
fact actually it was used all the time
with training of classical boltzmann
machines because they suffered from
horrible gradient decay problems when
looking at
discriminative
training objectives often and so you
they would you would typically begin
with a generative phase where you try to
generate training data and then finish
it off with a ordinary like you know
looking at the average success
probability of the classifier step
and so
this ends up kind of boiling down to a
question well can we do this well way
that we can do this is we can try to
find a hamiltonian
for the data
using the the previous methods that we
took a look at so by doing the gibbs
state optimization but in reverse where
we take the derivative of the
hamiltonian parameters to try to match
some training data we can find a thermal
state that actually does a pretty good
job of representing the training data
that ends up coming into it
and so once we've done that
what we we can do is we can then say
okay we've got a hamiltonian let's then
add a penalty term to our particular uh
hamiltonian that ends up coming in and
that will end up making our thermal
state
uh concentrated on the particular state
that you would like to uh try to
classify
so we put a penalty in order to be able
to make that state much more likely in
the distribution that ends up coming out
then we use a gibbs preparation method
in order to be able to do this that
gibbs preparation method could be a
number of different ideas we could try
to use an eth idea like brian ended up
suggesting we could use a metropolis
hastings type approach or we could even
use the methods the variational methods
i was talking about here in any case
what we do then is we use that in order
to generate an initial state and then we
finish it off with a vqe like
optimization over the quantum neural
network once we've input that into our
system
so we can use this kind of like a
preprocessing step in order to take our
initial state into something that is
close enough to the correct distribution
that we would like over the labels so
that
ordinary training can finish it up
that first equation
are all those letters that they should
be uh no the h uh sorry last minute
change the h should be an alpha
and the u's are
used uh the u's are the hamiltonian
coefficients so i might have called them
h previously i thought i fixed that oh
darn i missed that
this is what they're like the local
local police or something yeah yeah yeah
they're exactly they're like local
police
but um
so in in any case this is the idea for
it and then those those are the the
different parts of the optimization
process that would be handled by these
steps
and when you go through it the cost of
this whole protocol ends up scaling like
this where capital lambda is the
lipschitz constant l is you know the
number of terms that you end up having n
is the number of neurons in your system
and the rest of it end up depending on
the kind of the the properties of the
gibbs state that you're trying to
prepare
so
basically okay to conclude barren
plateaus can be a real
challenge
when it comes to quantum machine
learning and i think it's fair to say
that we don't have a universal solution
for barren plateaus in general
um and
they're especially pernicious in for
quantum neural networks because the
gradient is only learned by sampling we
can't rely on double precision
arithmetic to end up giving us a high
number of digits of accuracy for our
gradient at low cost
and furthermore you know um
we ended up seeing that generative
objective functions like this relative
entropy are not necessarily as prone to
barren plateaus although they can show
up under certain circumstances
and
in order for us to really despite the
fact that barren plateaus don't aren't
generically uh appearing such as in
this uh analysis that i alluded to here
we need to concern consider consider the
fact very carefully that the
that the uh result that we end up taking
a look at is a ratio of two numbers and
so we need to consider the computational
cost of estimating everything with an
epsilon air
because one of the dangers if you don't
pay attention to computational
complexity is you may find that you've
got a objective function that there's no
bearing plateaus for but it may be
exponentially hard to evaluate in that
case sure you solve one problem but at
the price of the other so one of the
things that i really strongly want to
advocate for that i think more people in
the machine learning community really
need to do is it's not enough i feel to
just take a look at gradients or and
take a look at how well the fully
trained model ends up performing we
really need to consider what the
computational complexity of absolutely
every step going into it is because you
can make these trade-offs right where
your gradients end up getting a lot
better
at the expense of the computational
complexity and potentially vice versa
however
under certain circumstances for high
temperature gibbs states the methods
that we we prepare give a good way for
you to be able to uh generatively learn
those particular states and uh
furthermore
kind of you know more tentatively this
might provide us an avenue that we could
use in order to in some cases escape
from the baron plateau problems that
we've seen in in qml
by generatively pre-training our initial
data to kind of make a wormhole between
the bad space in the optimization
landscape and the good space as close to
the solution that we'd like to be and
this might actually end up becoming an
important uh strategy in our fight to
try to finally build practical quantum
neural networks thank you very much
great thanks a lot yeah that was great
um
so um
let's see if if there have been plenty
of questions if there's a burning
question
uh please
please go ahead and ask now otherwise
we'll move on to the panel and
nathan if you stop sharing then
maybe yeah sure no problem you can start
building up the
video for the panel
okay so
so let's see um